[Musica]
tutto normale ragazzi tranquilli ci può
play questo a ok adesso adesso va molto
meglio perfetto da tutti ragazzi prima
di un attimo proposta cosa io pensavo di
essere messo male ha capelli ma porca
[ __ ]
guarda tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono valigie oggi siamo amateur
surgeon che sarebbe una roba molto più
professional rispetto a surgeon
simulator
anzi già che ci siamo ma è una presa per
il culo direi che possiamo partire però
prima di partire ragazzi sigla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
va bene va bene basta basta basta perché
il dottor house ci ha scassato lamin
comunque a parte questo andiamo su new
game non riuscire a me di via baby cela
la serietà di questo videogame già da
subito devo a io sono un pizzaiolo
perfetto ma perché qual è il senso c'è
un tizio per strada che somiglia
vagamente a uno zombie con la varicella
senza andarle a l'anprof fissa poi one
love is hard john moore idiota totò
riina cius bleed disgraziato vagante
morto probabilmente anche questa ragazzi
e una lacrima strappa storia e mi
dispiace veramente tanto oh mio dio ho
ucciso un vagabondo morto certo e
andiamo avanti a me mi dispiace non sono
morto veloce devi tagliarmi devi aprirmi
oddio santo o il coltello da pizza
perfetto allora possiamo eseguire
l'operazione ragazzi ci sia un uomo sexy
tra l'altro a start stato che possiamo
eseguire tra eccolo qui perfetta dalla
coltello da pizza che non so bene come
si chiami per beh vedo che sei messo
molto meglio di tanta gente che conosco
zero cioè una volta che mario vedi che
non è così male quello che hai subito
posso garantire devo mettere a posto le
ossa ma cazzo così va bene ma non è
difficile fare il chirurgo regalo false
cose quale facevo da piccolo con i
puzzle cazzo pensavo fosse chissà che
cosa fare chirurgia prima col secchio
favi jet ha grosse o attaccata profeta
mancano so vabbè mettiamo osso dicano
tanto è uguale perfetta thank you that
much better
adesso ho bisogno di essere chiuso ok
devo usare un ago avvisiamo il fuoco
fuoco e se ti brucia si capezzolo era
per essere un po e roma guarda come
promessi eccitato essa i capezzoli ni
del ragazzone che mi piace questo caso
adesso via al dolore perfetto gioco di
merda è una cosa veramente stupida
questo la pinzatrice è ovvio che cazzo
ne faccio ma devo chiudere tutto a
quello che la pinzatrice perfetto
ragazzi io sono un vero kg very nice
almost there prefetto il capezzolo ne
cela ancora qua cosa uso adesso dovrei
bruciarlo credo perfetto
non si fa un cazzo fantastico questo è
quest'uomo e iron man ragazzi oddio
perfetto adesso visto praticamente
smoccolando sul petto fantasma lavoro
superbo belgiovine cosa faccio adesso
finito cazzo vuole l'amica a curarli il
capezzolo sono perfetto o che madonna
quanta gente devo curare le curiamo al
ladro ragazza ovviamente che si
teletrasporta know i morti dentro il mio
garage ma dona che cazzo fase in groppa
tombetta e oggi il tuo giorno fortunato
perché posso e strati il vetro lo so che
stava tentando di fare l'amore con il
vetro però il problema non è questo
perché c'è dei denti che porca [ __ ]
non ti si possono guardare non sei vetri
in pancia nessuno ti guarda i denti
brutte possiamo fare che bello posso
bruciarti i capezzoli che il cameo
eccolo lì perfetto vedi che contento su
tutti contenti devo prenderla scusa zio
il mio compito da chirurgo e dar fuoco
alle ferite o da fuoco sono un piromane
ho capito sì l'ho preso
c'è l'ho ucciso perché ho appoggiato il
vetro sullo stomaco del tizio sono un
[ __ ] genio ragazzi hanno bravo zio
grava e dove l'appoggio spiegamelo
queste cazzate ma perché io sono molto
più stretti e le cose le poggio sul
paziente ormai ciò anche la motosega sul
suo braccio conca parte ste cagate
chiudiamo sta roba così se [ __ ]
perfetto che aveva il moccolo serve più
integrati nel caso mi sbucciate un
ginocchio
marco la tv addosso magari serve sembra
che ci siano più vecchie all'interno del
tagliare va col mancavano pure i vetri
interni ma vai che cazzo non potevi
mangiarci una pizza una parmigiana
invece di sti cazzo di vetri idiota che
è l'ultimo dio santo ti ringrazio
perfetto basta adesso mi ha rotto anche
questa che ottavio giustamente ho
tagliato io ma non la vuoi tenere per
ricordo che te l'ho fatta io tra fatah
zio favi questa è legata a fatah un
chirurgo qualsiasi come a terrei per
bellezza per tutti
il cazzo che vuoi l'importante è che tu
sia contento che i cerotti certe belle
mani che hai tra l'altro pensiamo al
prossimo la gag e vi sembra cletus cleto
son figo perché perché hai un porcospino
nellos che cazzo di problemi ai dalla
vita ai anche slacciato i pantaloni che
lo stava stuprando di la verità potreste
aiutare un amico
vabbè questo entra così a cazzo e per
chiedere se cose o certo ragazzi è ovvio
che è roba
aspetta un attimo che c'è mia madre che
ovviamente mi chiama se non è contenta
ha rotto la mamma ascom cavina si
aspetta aspetta sto per eseguire un
trapianto molto pesante quindi un
attimino per noi non lo salvano mag a
bondo ormai per mia madre è normale ce
ne frega un cazzo il porcospino l'ha già
rimosso va beh qualcuno
[ __ ] è mai sognato un freno non
regala mai a occhi chiusi
faccio il chirurgo faccio come hobby
come hobbit
ok le tue le tettine sono a posto altri
otto rifatto le tette fantastico
accogliamo tappi cazzo me le faccio il
cavatappi joe cassidy cavata prima ma
non urlare con una carica che hai
aiutato anche ciao ragazzi abbiamo anche
aiutato un tizio a guarire da un
porcospino non so se rendo l'idea
non mi danno il deep l'attestato per
miglior chirurgo al mondo dopo sta roba
mica
ormai avete dott mi fa una pippa a due
mani lega perfetto che cazzo vuole che
l'italia ancora il premier ma bruciati
cavin ombelico
niente ma avevo già tagliato ma che vuoi
ragazzi mi sta morendo mi sta morendo
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce micro
select repubblica si è a posto e ha
posto da ricucire di mamma donna che
palle se avessi saputo che avrei dovuto
cucire così tanto avrei fatto il sarto
porca migliorata bravo zio ancora ma che
cazzo ai trapianti di tekken 6 belle le
tette nuti che ti fai ma doc e palle
perfetti si fermano crepi perché lancio
il computer vi giuro ma crepando era che
non so se ce la faccio ci prova tre
giovani non vogliono morire morire non
morire non morire ma tu sei fuori ti
ammazzo giuro si no [ __ ]
[ __ ] lo sapevo che crepa lo sapevo
ero alla fine maledizione cioè ragazzino
mico adesso mi devo incazzare come non
so cosa ho messo gli anni perché
bellabarba adesso è anche le tette
rifatte zio sei contento contento ha
posto perfetto grazie a dio
viber crombie a fare il provino
direttamente zio che ti prendono che
cosa c'è di strano se tizio parte una
mano monca un cacciavite nel cervello si
sta bevendo dello slam
questo è un figo ha più cose lui addosso
che non so che io sto qua scova tutti
gli oggetti nel paziente all'interno
tutta roba che c'è dentro
avvisate nostra scherzare perché volevo
accendere le candeline tranquilli
se c'è un pezzo di metallo sulle tette
non è colpa mia scusa lo fa o good work
questo fatto cavatappi se io riuscissi a
togliere questo schifo iraq avete
presente ragazzi come si dice avere un
buco nello stomaco il cibo che volendo
ci puoi giocare a golf ma come cazzo di
chiude che ci mette un tappo di sughero
e non so che i ragazzi ecco questo a
cook è ok ragazzo mio avevi 4 capezzoli
fatto dire non è che posso passare la
mia vita a cucire un [ __ ] perfetto
perché parte che mancano 38 secondi
quindi che cazzo se grazie a dio già la
mano la mano la la usi per farti le pipe
zio perché finché stai messo troppo male
siamo arrivati ragazzi a 30 faccio
l'ultimo perché sono mica passiamo alla
vita a cucine persone perché c'è i
spongebob al posto della barba 0 ai
ragazzi non importa andiamo su trend
perché la cosa mi fa veramente strano
che il lavoro del chirurgo e un lavoro
serio perché bisogna non scoppiare a
ridere quando vedete la faccia dei
pazienti è una roba che questi come gli
tolgo spiazzo sono bulloni madonna
picchia proiettili se non avrai successo
come uomo potrei diventare groviera
fratello quindi tanta [ __ ] roba ce
l'abbiamo fatta
cos'è sta roba guarda il feto è incinta
e vero ragazzi il miracolo della vita
perfetto stai pagando un piglio molto
bello con tanto di lisca di pesce quando
mi vedete in giro non fatevi male per
qualsivoglia motivo perché potrei
curarvi in maniere che ve la ricorderete
per tutelarla cazzo c'hai da curare
ancora lo sterno clay doma stride lo
sguardo non mi crepare non mi prepara le
ragazze rimane troppo poca vita però non
ce la farò mai
non ce la farò mai ma ci provo non
regali rimane veramente troppo poco
impossibile che ai vai vai vai mai forse
sì forse anche rimane uno madonna
madonna madonna a due a due
oddio sì ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta
rega non sono un suo come c'è culo
pazzesco e basta basta non voglio sapere
come ho fatto nomi in testa va bene così
ce ne sono molti altri ma proprio tanti
ma proprio tanti cazzo quanta gente cioè
la madonna c'è pure wally c'è troppa
gente ragazzi lascio perdere per adesso
perché minchia mezz'ora di cure a cazzo
ragazzi una roba che non c'entra un
cazzo a sinistra del gioco c'è questo
che cazzo meglio devo giocare questa
roba che mi fissa e orribile sappiate
che nel 2015 porcospini sono alla moda
quindi non da domani tutti col
porcospino crisi ragazzi per ogni mi
piace a v da un vetro in meno per sto
tizio un porcospino in più per questo
spero che vide vi sia piaciuto e cosa
sento se vi sia piaciuto al trattamento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook che
condivide altra descrizione cioè se
presidente civile e non fatevi male che
poi so cazzi io vi ho avvertito da
ragazzi